valestia the world of Final Fantasy 16
is a dark place not just in the muted
color palette of Grays and Browns that
paint the castle keeps and bloody
Landscapes but in the ruthlessness of
the story within a history of betrayal
death Conquest War oppression and
whatever else comes to mind when you
think of a violent medieval setting are
integral to this new entry in the iconic
RPG franchise while these themes have
been present in the series in some form
Final Fantasy 16's opening makes it
abundantly clear that it's working in a
much more Grim context I recently got
Hands-On with what's roughly the first
four hours of Final Fantasy 16 during a
preview event and saw How The Story
begins it's heavy with cut scenes and
cinematic Flair using all the dazzling
visuals expected of a PlayStation 5
exclusive to deliver an opening act akin
to a Prestige drama the demo included
sequences of the main protagonist Clive
in his teenage years to show how tragedy
and his Royal Family's business fed into
a widespread war that carries into his
adulthood it was a vastly different
experience to my first preview which was
gameplay focused to showcase the depth
and intricacies of the game's stylish
action combat system so while I'll
preserve the more revelatory plot points
of this new story heavy preview there's
still plenty to parse because Final
Fantasy 16 is ambitious with its
narrative as you may know the story
ticks itself quite seriously and the
type of Whimsy you typically associate
with a final fantasy isn't really found
here Clive is from the rossfield family
who rule over the grand duchy of Rosaria
one of the key nations in valastia his
dad seems chill and his mom has an
arrogant Edge but both mean business
from the get-go what's interesting here
is that Clive is regarded as a talented
swordsman who can partially use effort's
powers yet he's not the one to inherit
the power of Phoenix which is passed
down through family Generations instead
that power went to his younger brother
Joshua who's a timid and soft-hearted
boy caught between his Royal Duty and
just wanting to be a kid this is how you
come to understand the role of dominance
the select few you who have the ability
to transform into icons which are
beastly god-like beings capable of mass
destruction it may seem like a blessing
but it is very much a curse which is
apparent in these early hours you see
that the two brothers truly care about
each other rather than having a strained
relationship marred by family drama
there's a sense of warmth in the few
scenes between them sharing their
insecurities portrayed in a genuinely
human light and I think this is one of
the critical areas where Final Fantasy
XV could Thrive for all its technical
prowess and flashy cinematics giving
characters moments to show their
Humanity amidst the world seemingly
devoid of it is one of the things that
Final Fantasy has historically done best
on the flip side my time with Final
Fantasy 16 also showed the ugliness of
humanity tragedy and betrayal befalls
Clive and his family and it's depicted
with a level of graphic detail that you
wouldn't expect from the series even
placing you within it with one of the
game's bespoke icon vs icon combat
scenarios but one of the strongest scene
means in terms of setting this tone was
when you flash forward to Clive's
adulthood as a bloody battle unfolds in
the background a meeting between leaders
of several Nations takes place tensions
Run High in this scene as characters
assert their Authority and show their
conniving side behind closed doors and
it's all brought together by sharp voice
acting we would before
raging outside you eventually see that a
significant part of Final Fantasy 16
story has to do with the enslavement of
certain types of magic users their tools
for war that are forced into labor and
treated as pawns it's brutal and reveals
a more complicated Dynamic to show how
dominance and some magic users are held
in high regard and others are kicked
into the dirt to serve a nation it's one
of the key areas I'm keeping a sharp eye
on because if they're not treated with
the right tone and level of nuance these
kinds of themes can ring Hollow Clive is
caught in the middle of all this having
been forced into serving the war because
of his combat talents but the story also
introduces the theme of Liberation in
these early hours as well sad office a
major character and the dominant of ramu
enters the scene to save Clive and you
learn that he's been staging a rebellion
freeing those who've been subjugated by
their Nations and providing respite for
them at a secret Hideaway which also
acts as the game's main Hub area despite
Clive's Newfound freedom and reuniting
with old friends he's solely focused on
C seeking revenge for what happened to
his brother Joshua all those years ago
it's the driving plot thread up to this
point and it's all Clive thinks about
but with all the chaos happening around
valestia I hope to see Clive grow into a
more dynamic character and be a strong
vehicle for connecting us to the complex
world that the story tries to set up
plot twists and narrative threads that
pose more questions and answers are
packed into this intro and for now I'm
left more intrigued and more eager to
see the story all the way through not
only are long timers of Final Fantasy in
for a new type of story they're in for a
completely different gameplay experience
while RPG elements are still present
this is by and large a fast-paced
stylish action game in the vein of Devil
May Cry yes Final Fantasy 15 and 7
remake Incorporated action elements but
they're a far cry from what combat
director ryoto Suzuki has cooked up here
his previous work on Devil May Cry 5
shows in Final Fantasy 16 and I gushed
about the flow of this new combat system
in my first gameplay focused preview
although Clive is the only controllable
character you switch between different
icons on the Fly who offer their own
unique abilities as if they're different
loadouts having customized my moveset
for Ifrit Garuda and Titan I was able to
pull off wild combos where I'd air
juggle enemies slam them into the ground
for heavy damage and keep the combo
rolling with gap closing abilities and
the bigger boss battles are challenging
in ways that test your ability to dodge
aoes and exploit the Stagger system
similar to 7 remake
if you're not attuned to this kind of
action game final fantasy 16 features a
set of equippable accessories that act
as gameplay assists allowing you to Auto
Dodge auto combo or slow down time to
help evade attacks for example those who
are in it for story content can simplify
the combat system for an easy going time
it also seems there's a high skill
ceiling from my experience especially
considering there's a super challenging
ultimania mode with leaderboards you'll
unlock after finishing the story however
having now played the opening hours it's
clear that it'll take some time to get
there it's important for the game to
work players up to the point of feeling
like an Unstoppable badass but I found
myself mostly matching the square button
to attack sprinkling in some ranged
magic shots and waiting for my one or
two icon abilities to refresh from
cooldown I've experienced what Final
Fantasy 16 plays like at a high level
it's thrilling and feels like it can
stand among the great stylish action
games that came before but you may be
wondering what all the fuss is about in
these early hours
part of why I've cherished Final Fantasy
over the decades is because of its
ability to be spirited and poignant in
the face of tragedy so I think it's key
to not conflate a darker tone and
maturity while Final Fantasy 16 is
mature in the M rated sense the lessons
and themes I've Come Away with from
other games in the franchise are as
sobering as they've always been yet I
still feel that Final Fantasy can be
whatever it wants to be it's up to the
creators which direction they want to
take it so from that perspective I'm as
fascinated in this new entry as any
other that's come before it especially
since it's coming from creative business
unit 3. the folks behind Final Fantasy
XIV the team's MMORPG has transcended
the genre norms and has become one of
the greatest stories told in the
franchise I've seen what the developers
can do with strong interpersonal stories
lovable characters captivating political
drama and Powerful moments that fuse
gameplay and narrative beautifully and
when it comes to the balance between
inspiring heroics and levity brutal
realities and sometimes the goofiness
necessary to find joy and dark times few
games do it as well as Final Fantasy 14.
Final Fantasy 16 is another Beast for
sure but it's exciting to see this team
try something different and show what
they can do outside of the critically
claimed MMORPG as is the case with many
RPGs the most burning questions I have
are never going to be answered by any
demo trailer or piece of marketing
material as intriguing as the story has
been thus far and as hyped as I am about
the stylish action combat part of me
still holds on to this abstract idea of
what Final Fantasy is and this new
Mainline entry may be deviating further
from it than ever before but if there's
a team I trust most with taking the
series in New Directions it's the folks
who've made Final Fantasy 14 what it is
today and we'll be able to see for
ourselves soon when Final Fantasy 16
Launches on June 22nd exclusively for
PlayStation 5.